qué medidas deberían implementarse para
comenzar a abordar la menstruación como
un tema de salud
hola buenas noches a todas las personas
inocentes
bueno nosotros desde mexico hemos
impulsado muchísimos temas pero entre
los más importantes son la eliminación
del iva de los productos de la gestión
mensual que en mexico es el 16 por
ciento que pagamos del impuesto por
estos productos y además impulsar la
gratuidad de estos productos de tanto
toallas japonés como copas o cualquier
otro producto la gestión menstrual y
además una educación de calidad y que
hay una investigación al respecto porque
en la actualidad pues no hay datos
acerca de qué es lo que pasa cuando las
mujeres u otras personas migrantes
estamos mejorando
y claro que nosotros estamos totalmente
de acuerdo con lo que se acaba de
declarar de que la menstruación tiene
que ser un derecho humano porque para
muchas personas es un obstáculo para
acceder a derechos tan básicos como la
educación por ejemplo en mexico 4 de
cada 10 niñas prefieren no ir a la
escuela cuando están menstruales
ahora por dónde empezar porque el tema
sigue siendo un estigma en escuelas
lugar en el trabajo etcétera incluso
dentro de la misma familia y bueno
nosotras alzamos la voz en el tema de
incidencias en legislación y políticas
públicas pero siempre decimos a las
personas que pueden hacer su cambio
desde tu propia familia no empezar por
mencionar la palabra administración como
tal porque existen muchísimas palabras
para invisibilizar la y hacerla un
estigma y un tabú
entonces ya mencionando la hablando de
una manera positiva
empezando a hablar de estos temas porque
se nos cobra un impuesto por los
productos de gestión menstrual o porque
no son gratuitos porque al final de
cuentas por ejemplo en méxico somos más
de la mitad de la población
increíble que no existieran políticas
públicas o legislaciones que nos dieran
estos productos gratuitamente
y ahora cuáles son precisamente estos
estigmas que siguen teniendo sino de la
menstruación y cómo afecta a la
respuesta como un problema de salud
bueno entre los muchos estigmas por
ejemplo nos decían cuando hicimos una
encuesta en comisión mexico y pin ángel
o y muchas más organizaciones en
menstruación y ambientes escolares nos
decían que por ejemplo los profesores no
los dejaban a las niñas salir más de una
vez a ir al baño cuando estaban
menstruando y por eso no asistían a la
escuela o que no había las condiciones
de infraestructura como baños agua
potable papel higiénico en las escuelas
o que sus compañeros se burlaban cuando
se manchaban la ropa de sangre entonces
todos esos estigmas son los que le hacen
que la menstruación no sea digna para
las mujeres y otras personas de nuestro
antes